so if you look at the the wealthiest
people in the world most of them
made their money in punctuated periods
of time
and so there are these these gaps of
arbitrage that get exposed for
that i mean that thing like no
opportunities forever right you get
these periods of time where there's
disproportionate return
on investment right kevin harrington
made all of his money because a certain
period of time
he was able to get infomercial time
eight hours a day for free
for three years they just had no one
they had no programming
so he literally ran infomercials for
eight hours a day on national television
for free and just killed it he had no
cost of acquisition he literally
sold for eight hours a day on national
television
and the majority of his money was made
from that and then the rest of his life
has been like
trying to find little pockets right mark
cuban made most of his thing on one sale
kevin o'leary yeah most of it on one
deal right and so
there are these arbitrage opportunities
that open up and they close and what we
have to do as entrepreneurs is
look at the skills that we need to have
so we have a full stack of skills so
that when that door opens
we can go all in and put everything on
black
you